Elmau Palace at the foot of the Wetterstein mountains on Germany's southern border.
It's an enchanting location that attracts
not only tourists
but some of the world's finest musicians.
Famous visitors have included Benjamin Britten,
London's legendary Amadeus Quartet
and violin virtuoso Yehudi Menuhin.
There are more than 200 top flight evening
concerts at Elmau Palace every year, mostly
featuring jazz and classical music.
Sometimes there's chamber music.
Here guests are treated to a quartet with
violinist Lisa Batiashvili
and violist Antoine Tamestit.
“Elmau palace is my favorite place in the
world.
Time passes differently here.
The air is different.
It's a world unto itself.”
Musicians here don't get paid their usual
appearance fees.
Instead they get a couple of days free residence,
including gourmet food.
“Food is something essential for the artists
who come here.
For them, everything aesthetic and sensual
is of the highest importance.
They're the most discerning guests a hotel
can have .”
And the man in charge of the guests' culinary
well-being is Mario Corti.
He's been Elmau Palace's executive chef since
2010.
The hotel's flagship restaurant is the Luce
d‘ Oro, a tiny gourmet eatery seating 35.
It's had a Michelin star for several years.
“A gourmet restaurant is great advertising
for a complete culinary concept.”
But Corti is also responsible for everything
some 70 chefs serve
in the hotel's eight other restaurants.
“We cook very international food.
We don't want to limit ourselves to any one
style,
say classic French with Euro-Asian influences.
We use seasonal products.
We cook with passion using many ingredients
from the region.”
One of the most popular dishes is filet of
Wagyu beef
with white and green asparagus and potatoes.
“Here we have some wonderful Wagyu Beef.
It comes from our friend Sepp Krätz at the
German Wagyu Academy.
It's one hundred percent pure Wagyu beef,
born and bred in Bavaria.
It's wonderfully marbled.”
“Preheat the oven to 90 degrees Celsius
then bake the seared meat for around 12 minutes.
Then let it stand briefly.
Sautee it again in butter, and you've got
the perfect steak.”
“Here's some grade A asparagus, juicy and
just harvested.”
“You glaze the asparagus very slowly, with
a bit of salt,
a pinch of sugar and some poultry stock.
It's cooked through very slowly in its own
juices.”
Here we have some nice potatoes from the region
cut into squares.
We fry them slowly so that roasting aromas
can develop.
Just adding a little butter and some parsley.
Cherry tomatoes, radishes, some herbs and
a lug of good olive oil
give the whole thing some freshness."
Filet of Wagyu beef with asparagus is a luxurious
dish.
The meat costs several hundred euros a kilo.
The food and the music are a perfect combination.
“It rare to spend the whole day in the same
place as the audience.
You meet people in the restaurant, in the
spa or outside.
It feels very natural.
Very intimate.
It's fun sharing you're music with these people.”
The fine food and fine music of Elmau Castle
are no secret.
Enthusiasts flock to this remote and enchanting
location.